il y a trente ans les haïtiens défiait
les tontons macoutes les tortionnaires
du régime pour réclamer plus de libertés
et moins une misère la révolte populaire
mettait fin à 28 ans de dictature
sanglante des duvalier père et fils le
président à vie bébé doc fuyaient le
pays le 7 février 1986 trente ans plus
tard jour pour jour un autre président
quitte le pouvoir
volontairement cette fois de l'est
pouvoir ouvrant plus je n'ai jamais
voulu rester au pouvoir un jour de plus
que prévu dit il
mais l'an dernier michel martelly a
reporté de quatre mois le premier tour
des présidentielles et il a dû repousser
puis annuler le deuxième tour en janvier
en raison des violences et du boycott du
scrutin
le président a donc cédé sa place son
successeur provisoire sera élu par les
parlementaires
le problème c'est que les institutions
démocratiques en haïti ne sont pas
vraiment indépendants les fruits des
réformes promises après la chute de
duvalier se font encore attendre
il ya eu quand même des gens qui
risquaient leur vie pour avoir un
lendemain meilleur
et quand et jean claude est parti et
tout l'espoir était là mais
malheureusement et on a connue en
ce qu'on a vu actuellement cet animateur
de radio à interviewer presque tous les
présidents haïtiens depuis les duvalier
pour lui la seule élections vraiment
libres et démocratiques étaient celles
de 1990 le pape que de réussir avec jean
bertrand aristide
la désillusion est brutale car le prêtre
incarné tous les espoirs
chaque élection semble faire avancer
puis reculer la démocratie
malgré tout les haïtiens ont fait un
gain important depuis 30 ans une liberté
d'expression et de presse qui force de
plus en plus les élites à rendre des
comptes
je pense qu'on a quand même faire un pas
et en avant mais tant et aussi longtemps
et qu'on pense à des pouvoirs personnels
et non voire en fait l'intérêt de la
nation
on va continuer à patrouiller le
président intérimaire devra organiser le
deuxième tour des présidentielles qui
doit maintenant avoir lieu le 24 avril
ici sophie langlois radio canada
montréal